[Music]
the owners of the Wilson Creek Winery in
Temecula are Route 91 survivors and this
year they're helping sponsor the
Remember music festival here in Las
Vegas Kirsten Joyce tells us more about
how through the sales of their special
wines they're helping fund the love wins
Foundation
do you remember it like it was yesterday
Bill and Jennifer Wilson survived one
October recently at a Kenny Chesney
concert we're in uh Sofi Stadium I'm
looking around going
I just had just a little moment of whoo
here we go
um you're always aware now of where the
exit is and what's going on yeah you
think differently your mind takes you
back there but love wins love wins
closer together now after living through
the trauma they found their Inner
Strength a push to live their best lives
it was definitely hey let's start taking
time for ourselves as the five-year
anniversary approaches they continue to
help others solidify theirs that's what
this whole project is about is to help
everybody get over that next step of
whatever that step they're going through
in their life the couple owns Wilson
Creek Winery in Temecula one year after
the tragedy they began creating special
wines to fundraise For A Cause connected
to one October this year four special
Blends on sale for the number of days
forever connected with one October 58
days if we did put them on sale earlier
this year than any year because of the
five year because they were done and
looked really great we just got them out
there we've had so many people stop in
we've seen it all over social media with
the specific Route 91 Facebook sites and
things like that people are really
appreciative and they look forward to
getting a label every year this year
money raised from the wine sales goes to
the love wins Foundation this particular
Foundation love wins is now contributing
to the monument that will be there on
the grounds of the festival where the
festival was a lot of people are afraid
a lot of people have this traumatic
memory and you kind of have to keep it
alive to then overcome it as each year
passes Bill and Jennifer connect with
new friends who have been impacted by
one October and they continue to support
the healing process for all survivors
next Saturday one of the survivors of
Chelsea Romo lost her eye and she's
getting married here at the winery and
going to have her reception in our
backyard so we're excited for her and um
we are also planning with others to go
back you know for October 1st this year
so I think it's going to be a really
great group of people that are going to
be back there all together supporting
each other
now in addition to the wine sales the
couple held a special concert and all
the proceeds from it also go to the love
wins Foundation